In breaking news, governments worldwide
are voting to choose the smartest person
on Earth to represent humanity and make
first contact with the alien vessels.
Negotiations collapsed 6 months ago.
Panic is spreading worldwide tonight as
the arrival of the unidentified vessels
triggers states of emergency across
every continent. Imagine they come in
peace. No lasers from the sky. Imagine
they come
in just hovering in the sky.
[Music]
Okay, guys. I snuck past the military
and I'm literally under the alien ship
right now. If this gets a million likes,
I'll go beyond the fence.
All right, folks. Time for the meet
aliens Tik Tok challenge.
Light it, genius. Oh my god, they are
definitely here for us. Anyway, you can
learn more by buying my brand new online
course, Learn How to Channel with
Aliens. Pop entertainer Glitzy Vondrax
has officially nominated herself to
represent humanity in first contact with
the alien vessels. Entertainer Glitzy
Vondrax cited her brief suborbital space
flight and quote totally eyeopening
experience as qualifications for the
role. Honestly, I feel like this is my
moment. I've been mentally preparing to
meet aliens ever since I did my trip to
space.
Aliens are here. UFOs are here. The news
is covering it. Everybody's covering it.
What are we supposed to do now that it's
finally here? Now that AI is finally
here to where all you have to do is type
out a prompt. You type text and VO3 is
the new AI technology that you literally
type out a prompt and it gives you these
photorealistic cinematic video with
sound effects, with voiceovers, with lip
syncing everything. We were making fun
of Will Smith shoving spaghetti in his
mouth and it was going through his
fingers. And we're talking about how AI
doesn't know how to make fingers without
adding an extra finger. And we're making
fun of AI. And this whole time I've been
saying it's evolving itself
exponentially. Every second of every
moment of every day, it's evolving and
getting better and better. And so we've
been thinking, you know, maybe a couple
years down the road, we're not even
going to be able to tell the difference
between AI and reality anymore. But
we're there. I mean, this is this is
like so quickly happening. And those
clips that I just showed you guys were
actually on a channel called
Understanding Conspiracy with Paul Stab.
He actually got to jump on this before I
did. So, I wanted to just react to some
of the stuff that he was saying because
he's thinking along the same lines that
I am about how this AI technology can be
used to enslave humanity, to deceive
humanity. We know that the dragon is
going to deceive the entire world. How's
he going to do that? Well, all of us,
literally all of us have one of these in
our pockets. And if you can't tell the
difference in reality and AI, then how
are we going to know? How are we going
to be able to trust anything that's on
the news, anything that's on social
media, anything that's on the
television? You can't. I mean, already
some of these boomers out there are
sharing pictures, AI generated pictures
that are obviously AI. Some third world
country kid who built a gorilla out of
Coca-Cola bottles and they're getting
shared and thousands of people are
saying, "Amen. Amen." Well, thankfully
most of those are AI generated. Even the
comments I I think that even AI is
creating the profiles, creating the
pictures, making the post and all the
people that are commenting are AI too.
This is what they call the dead internet
theory that AI is literally going to
take over the whole internet and but
there are still I see all the time I see
Simpsons graphics being shared that are
saying that they're predictive
programming when they're obviously AI
generated. There's like two Bart
Simpsons and you know Maggie has uh
three legs or something crazy. I've been
messing with AI for well about three
years and it has a certain look that I
can always tell. It's like an
oversaturation, a super clean and shiny.
Um it just looked too perfect kind of.
But now I mean it's getting to where you
can't even tell a difference. But I I
want to let Paul talk real quick. Um
this is what he shared today or
yesterday on his channel called
Understanding Conspiracy. And I'm I'm
following right with what he's saying.
He got on it before I did. And I just
want you guys to hear what he says. It
only feels literally like yesterday, not
even that long ago. I was kind of
discussing the advancements of AI
generative image making and movies
saying this is pretty crazy. This is
pretty realistic, you know? I mean uh
can you imagine what it's going to be
like in 10 years
time quite naively not realizing a week
later suddenly it's just improved
100fold the technology that we have that
the civilians of the public have believe
me are 10 years obsolete I mean what the
powers that be the elites of the world
they have technology at least 10 years
more advanced than we do that's not a
conspiracy theory That's just reality.
You think that the government um created
or the military created AI technology
and they're like, "Hey, we ought to just
share this with the public because it
would be a lot of fun, right?" No.
There's always secrecy, top secret, all
these concerns, right? They're they're
worried about cyber threats and all this
stuff. They're not going to give the
public what they have. So, mind blown,
right? They have stuff that's way better
than what we're seeing right now. How
long have they had it? How many events
out there could have just been
completely AI generated and put on the
news as reality? Whoa. That makes you
think, doesn't it? These are what AI
clips look like now. If I wasn't tipped
off that this was AI, I might really it
it might really fool me. I It might have
really slipped under my radar. Check
this out. Welcome to the Chernobyl
challenge. I'm going to lick this
glowing pole. Let's see how many views
this gets.
bathing in liquid cement until it
hardens. Let's get solid.
Digging to the earth's core. Bare hands.
No breaks. Counting every grain of sand
on this beach. Let's go. 1 2 3 4. I'm
doing K2 the honest way. Alone,
unprepared, and in a straight line.
Leave a comment for the search team.
Flying into North Korea with a lawn
chair and 1,000 party balloons. Don't
try this at home.
I'm about to survive a 100 days in the
African savannah, only eating and
drinking what my body already gave up.
Basically, the circle of life. Hey guys,
welcome back to the channel. Today,
we're cooking with plutonium 239. It's
hot, it's dangerous, and it's definitely
illegal. You cannot tell this stuff is
AI. like we've kind of seen the little
evolution. So, we're kind of like, "Oh,
wow. That's crazy that AI got this
advanced." But imagine showing these
clips to somebody 50 years ago, 10 years
ago, five years ago. Five years ago, I
would not know that this is fake. I'd
have no clue, zero clue, because I
wouldn't know that this existed. I I
heard about Midjourney was the first AI
technology that I had ever heard of, a
image making technology and that was
maybe three years ago and it was like
back then it was everybody had weird
fingers and potato faces and especially
like mush faces in the background. But
um this I'm looking at it right now
knowing it's AI. I cannot see any
evidence. She's wearing a microphone. I
mean, I cannot see any evidence. There's
I can see a window reflected in her oven
back there. I can see reflections in the
pot. There's nothing to give this away
except that I know where AI has advanced
to. I mean, this is insane. So, what is
the danger of this type of technology?
It it seems really cool, right? It's
like, hey, I could I could make a movie
myself. It really is. It's like leveling
the playing field. We could make
Christian films. We could illustrate the
Bible. We could we could make a Bible
movie and you could just hire a team of
five people making $20 an hour and
everybody be happy, right? Like, oh, I
love I love going to my job where I just
uh type prompts and I get to build a
Bible movie and I make $20 an hour and
you don't have to pay a billion dollars
for a movie. But what are the downsides
to this deception? Like crazy. So, it
was a year ago or so that I remember
seeing um a woman maybe in her 50s, no
maybe in her 60s. Anyway, a woman who
wasn't that old. She wasn't elderly, but
she was boomer age. And she got a phone
call on Messenger. I'm talking like
video phone call from her friend. and
her friend was on this glitchy camera
and she was saying, "Hey, I'm I'm in
trouble. Can you send me some money?"
And then the phone dropped out. And so
they started typing and she figured out
where she needed to send the money to.
Sent the money to her and found out it
wasn't her friend. It was a total deep
fake video on a messenger phone call,
which I don't even know what kind of
method you have to do to get yourself on
a Messenger phone call using a deep
fake, but this was a year ago, dude.
Now, imagine what they can do now. I
mean, the deception is going to be
insane. So, here's a couple other clips
because I want to show you like how real
this is. Look at look at this right now.
You're seeing a reflection of what's in
that room on the door. This is flawless.
Now, this is all going to be news clips
because the news is like so easy to
fake. I mean, you got somebody who's
barely moving. They're sitting still
basically and the background is just
simple stuff. Desks, TVs, things like
that, and they already talk, you know,
weird. Anyway, I remember as a kid being
like, why do why do newscasters talk
like that? Check this out.
Here are today's top news. To ensure
only the best words are used, White
House speech announces new thesaurus
with all synonyms replaced by Trump. In
shocking speech, White House announces
plan to replace all US ambassadors with
highly opinionated game show hosts for
more entertaining diplomacy. The White
House unveils Truth GPT, an AI that
rewrites all social media posts globally
to reflect undisputed facts up
tremendously. White House announces AI
will now write all press briefings to
ensure 100% factual
incomprehensibility. White House speech
reveals plan to resolve international
trade deficits by challenging other
nations to highstakes Mara Lago croquet
matches. In a bid to combat
misinformation, AI content generators
begin. All right, we don't got to watch
all of it, but that was all AI every
clip. I mean this if you type on uh
YouTube, type VO VO3, you're gonna find
tons of clips that just came out two
days ago at the latest a week ago. The
oldest clips I'm find a week ago. The
the internet is blowing up right now
with these montages of this app. And
we're talking about an app that's less
than $300 a month, which it does sound
like a lot, but imagine if you're making
a movie or imagine if you're scamming
people and you're making way more than
$300 a month. Like, this is insane.
Where are we going to be in one year?
One year. This happened in a
month. So, check out what Paul says
here. Just hypothetically here. Just
imagine they pulled another 2020 on us,
but this time it was for real. and you
really were locked down. Martial law in
your home, you cannot leave type of
stuff. And there's there's literally
soldiers posted on every street who will
just take you out. For your own safety,
you must remain indoors. And a lot of
people will comply. If that did happen
and all you've got is a device and then
you need to start getting your
information on what's going on in the
outside world from that device. you have
no other means to know what's going on
outside of cuz no there's no
communication. Then they could roll out
a full fake spectacle that is only real
on the actual black cube. It's only real
on this. It's not real in anything else.
But you wouldn't know the difference.
You would assume everything they're
showing you is true, right? The timing
of the release of this technology is
actually quite useful for a current
going on right now. So he goes on to
say, I mean, this is like the perfect
plan, right? Remember how they had
everybody locked down, but it was kind
of like, well, you can go to the grocery
store. You can do these like necessity
type things. What if they're saying
they're here, this is alien invasion.
Nobody come out of their homes. If you
come out of your homes, we will detain
you. I mean, people in fear will stay in
their homes for one because they don't
want to be detained, for another because
they don't want to face an alien. And
what they're seeing on their screen is
things that they can't look out their
window and see. Like the news is in
America, the news is saying, uh, this is
what's going on in Australia right now.
This is what's going on in Africa right
now. And in other countries, like in
London and things like that, they're
seeing this is what's going on in New
York. So, we can't even fact check it
because you can't look out the window
and see it. We're all seeing news that's
saying they're here. Stay in your homes
because we don't know if they're friend
or foe.
That's crazy. But this is what I think
is going on with um things like CERN and
Blue Beam and all that stuff. People
think that we're building these
Stargates. Like Stargates that are going
to use technology to usher in Satan. I
don't think he needs technology to
manifest in this world. Angels manifest
all the time. You read the Bible. An
angel came to Daniel. An angel came to
Abraham. And or three angels came to
Abraham. Jacob wrestled an angel. Uh
Mary saw an angel. Joseph saw an angel.
Right? So all these people had
encounters with angels and there was an
angel sitting on a rock when Jesus came
out of the tomb and it frightened the
people that were watching. We know that
in the Bible angels appeared as men. It
literally just says uh two men appeared
in white apparel and asked what are you
gazing at? You know, like the Bible
always just talked about they were
physical. When they met with Abraham, he
was running around and like cooking for
them and feeding them and they were
eating with him. Angels were eating. So,
we know that angels can manifest. They
can appear as men. Uh we hear stuff all
the time about people seeing, you know,
creatures
and angels of light that are most likely
deceptive. So, even Satan and his angels
have the ability to manifest in this
world. But what I think is going on with
building a Stargate and all this stuff
is Satan still has to play by the rules,
right? There's there's rules of
engagement. There's a a judicial system
in the spirit world where Satan isn't
allowed to go wherever he's not invited.
But that invitation can come through
many different forms. when you start
watching the P-word or sexual immorality
or uh ingesting drugs and alcohol and
playing with tarot cards and having
dream catchers on your wall and and
decorative idols and things like that in
your home. These are all secular music
movies. These are all things that are
inviting Satan into your home. Now, what
I think is happening with when they're
building CERN and all this stuff
is this is a huge invitation for the
enemy because these people that are
building this thing, they want something
to come through there. They want some
kind of physical contact. They're trying
to communicate with interdimensional
beings. And just like that Ouija board,
it's a piece of cardboard with a little
plastic oracle. There's no power in the
ga in the game. But when you pull that
game out and you put your hands on it
and you say, "Okay, spirits, I want to
hear something, uh, you know, speak to
me." Now, Satan says, "They've given me
permission." And and legally, Satan has
the right to come in and communicate. If
you draw a big pentagram on the ground
and stand in the middle of it and start,
you know, cing spells, there's really no
power in any of that. All that is is a
is a beacon to Satan saying, "I'm
inviting you in. come now reveal
yourself. So when they're building these
big CERN hydron colliders and all that I
think this is a a largecale invitation
and this is how Satan's going to
manifest and appear as Christ on earth
and he's going to deceive millions. You
guys might know Aaron Parallax. We were
on the phone and he was telling me he
said, "You know, I think that AI is
going to be what commu what contacts
aliens, the first alien contact." And I
was like I I didn't really I wasn't
following at first. I was like, uh, I
don't know how how that's going to work
or what you mean exactly. But then I
just got on Google and I typed AI
contact aliens and right away he didn't
even know this. I told him while I was
on the phone with him I was like dude
like they're already talking about this
article is from this first article from
Scientific Americas from July of last
year. It says artificial intelligence
will let humanity talk to aliens. Forbes
magazine a year ago. Beyond the Stars,
AI's breakthrough mission to discover
talking to
extraterrestrials. National Space
Agency.gov communication with
extraterrestrial intelligences.
Actually, I'm not even sure if that's
talking about AI, but this is a a
national security
agency.gov talking about communicating
with extra extraterrestrials, which we
know are demonic. So, our government,
national security is talking about
communicating with demonic beings under
the guise of
extraterrestrial. New York Post, aliens
most likely to contact artificial
intelligence. BBC, how AI is helping the
search for extraterrestrial life.
Artificial intelligence software is
being used to look for signs of alien
life forms. Uh, Drury Mirror. I'm not
even sure what that is, but the use of
AI in the search for extraterrestrial
life. Popular mechanics. AI is actually
a form of alien intelligence, says
Harvard University. That was this year.
That was March. That was just last
month. Well, two months
ago. So, I mean, we're already there.
Like, we're already seeing articles
saying that we're using AI to try and
reach out to aliens. Now, there's some
people that think that AI is completely
demonic. It's just this demonic entity.
I don't believe that. I'm not going to
step out on a limb and say that I think
the whole thing is demonic, just like I
don't think a TV is demonic. I don't
think a cell phone is demonic. This is
technology that can be used for good or
for evil. But
ultimately, all technology ends in the
hands of evil. It always does because
Satan is the god of this world. We
wrestle not against flesh and blood, but
against principalities, against the
powers of darkness, and against the
rulers of this world. The rulers of this
world are ruled by Satan. They're the
puppets for Satan, the puppet master.
And so, of course, when you start
building AI robots, like Elon Musk, who
says there's going to be like two robots
per human on Earth, that's a dangerous
thing. Yes, they can be useful. they can
help you um go to the grocery store.
Like especially with disabled people and
that's what they always do, man. They
always introduce this stuff like
microchipping your brain. Introduce it
by saying, "Look, it can make people it
can make blind people see again. It can
make people's uh crippled people be able
to walk again." And you're like, "This
is amazing. Yes, let's fund the mic the
brain chip." But that's just the
propaganda to get you to accept it. And
yes, they're going to have some people
that are it's probably going to help.
Same with these AI robots. You know, if
if somebody's disabled and can't go to
the store to get their medicine or
something like that, the AI can do it.
The robot can do it. Or go out in your
yard and garden. But what's going to
happen is it's going to take everybody's
jobs already. Hollywood is cooked.
Hollywood has no job. Dude, you can make
a you can make Hollywood budget movies
in your home typing text out. So, you're
talking actors, voice over artists,
script writers,
cinematographers, sound engineers. I
mean, they hire people just to make
sound effects in movies, like the sound
of feet walking on rocks. We're talking
Uber drivers, self-driving cars,
employees. I mean, at Walmart, we're
already checking out our own groceries,
right? So, we're already getting rid of
cashiers, robots that can stock
shelves. This is not too far away.
Basically, any kind of computer job is
is gone. Programming, like I said,
narration, sub subtitling or or dubbing,
if you're a narrator, you or you're a
translator, like your job is gone. So,
what's going to happen when everyone
loses their job? And we actually Elon
talked about this. I did a video a while
back showing an interview where Elon
said, "We're going to have to figure out
some kind of form of new currency
allowance basically because AI is going
to take over so many jobs that if we
don't do something, the economy is going
to collapse and there's going to be
chaos." Because when people don't eat
for a day or two or a week, that's
chaos. Literally chaos.
And so they have to come up with a form
of currency that we get like allowances.
Like we're all going to get some monthly
check or what do they call it? Social
credit score or something, right? So the
world is is about to change
rapidly. The there's no stopping this.
There's no like whatever you're
fear-mongering. This is this is insane.
That's not going to happen for a hundred
years. No, it's here. So major changes
are about to happen. 2025 is insane,
guys. We know that there's going to be a
one world order that's literal control,
like prison world. So, we know there's
going to be a one world
religion. We know that Satan is going to
deceive the entire world. So, how's that
going to happen? 2025, we're already
here, man. So, Trump, he can make any
religious law. All right? So when the
new world religion is enforced, he can
do that. Um, the one world order. Well,
Trump already was saying in the first
month that he was president, uh, yes,
guys, let me get the AI team out here.
We want to unroll Stargate. And what is
Stargate? It is total AI
surveillance. 100% everything is survey
is surveillanced by AI.
Okay. And the and the guy who created it
said, "People will behave. Even
policemen will behave when AI is
watching every move you make." Okay. So
now we're tracked everywhere. I mean, we
already track ourselves. Like we we have
a tracking device willfully on us at all
times. These things listen to us. I can
prove it 100% that I can say something
around this phone and I'll get an ad for
it. I can talk about dog food. Dog food.
I don't even have a dog. I don't buy dog
food, but tomorrow I'm going to see an
ad for dog food because that's the way
it works. And I'll post a picture of it.
So, we're being tracked. We get we get a
little percentage off our meal if we
check in. So, we're already being
groomed to tell everybody where we're at
at all times. I was at the Mexican
restaurant. I saved 10% by checking in,
right? This is all grooming us for the
social credit system that's coming. So
when you go to the New World Church and
you check in and say, "I was a good
citizen today. I went to church." Your
credit
score, oh, you get a really good credit
score when you go to the New World
Church because when you go there, it's
helping humanity to be a better place,
to be happier, to be more loving, to be
more accepting of everyone, and to not
be a bigot, and not to be uh
discriminatory. So, if you go to the New
World Church, you get a a lot of big
score and that's going to help you to
drive your Ubers. That's going to help
you to get your groceries. But if you
don't, oh man, that's really going to
dock your score down. So, we got
Stargate watching everything. Cell
phones already programming us to do this
social credit system thing because like
Elon said, we're not going to have jobs
anymore. We have to get our our currency
is going to be different. It's not going
to be like, "Look, I can just make money
and I can buy whatever I want. I don't
have to go to that church or whatever."
No, you're not. That money is not going
to be worth anything. You can't eat
money. You can't eat cash. So, you're
going to have to conform to the new
credit score system, the social credit
score. So, we got Trump, he's he can
make any law about religion. We got the
total surveillance, even the the Golden
Dome.
You know, I I made a video on that
saying that he wants to protect us from
outside threats and this is, you know,
part of the war against the coming of
Christ, but it could also be just our
prison being built all around us and
we're like, "Yes, protect us from the
threats out there." And really, it's
like, "No, you're a slave and you're
you're bound to this system
now." And then the coming
aliens, quote unquote, aliens. Satan is
going to deceive the entire world. How's
he going to do it? Well, the Bible says
that Revelation says that three unclean
spirits like
frogs, think about what an alien gray
looks like. Think of anything in nature
that an alien gray looks like. Three
unclean spirits like frogs are the
spirits of devils which go to the
militaries of the world. The kings and
the militaries of the earth. Who's
telling us that these things are real?
The military having US congressional
hearings. They're real. We've been
talking to them. non-human
intelligences. And when they come, this
is what Revelation says. These three
unclean spirits are going to unite the
militaries of the world together, United
Nations, to fight against the coming of
Christ. So, what I think is going to
happen is we're going to have soft
disclosure along the way. They know that
if they just say aliens are here,
there's going to be utter chaos, panic,
all that. So that's why we've had these
little things, little disinformation,
misinformation, leaks, whistleblowers.
There's no such thing as a whistleblower
on mainstream media news. There's no
such thing as a leak in the mainstream
media. This is all purposefully done. If
you're buying into this thinking that
you're tracking along, you have been
duped because I was duped. I thought the
same thing. I all my life I've been
intrigued by this alien topic and I
thought that I was catching on. I
thought that I had all the secrets and I
was like, they're hiding the truth.
truth. I want to know the truth. We
demand to know the truth. So, all these
little things, all these little We found
a We found a craft and we picked up a
craft that's on the news. Um, hey, we're
seeing sightings all around, but the
next thing to come, which I believe, and
me and Aaron were talking about this, he
put this in my
mind that AI is going to make
communication because look, AI is not
bound by anything, no language, no
nation, whatever. It's far and wide.
It's literally like the Tower of Babel.
Genesis said when they were building the
Tower of Babel, God said, "All the
people are as one, and this they think
to do, build a tower to heaven." And
what are we doing all the time?
Launching rockets to the heavens, right?
We're doing the same thing. Only he said
that when all their languages were
together, they they thought this wicked
thing to do. So God had to confound
their languages. What's happening now?
AI, no language barrier, and we're
already seeing that it's reaching out
trying to look for for intelligent life
out there, right? So, what's going to
happen is the news is going to say,
well, science today says that we found
communication from another planet out in
the universe, a planet we didn't even
know existed. But this is what the
message says. Greetings, Earthlings. We
have been watching you since the first
atomic bomb. And we've been we've been
trying to get in touch with you, but we
didn't want to frighten you. So, this is
the best way to communicate with you.
And we want to help you. There is an
evil alien invader coming to take over
your planet. And if you don't side with
us, you're never going to survive. They
will enslave you and take you over. But
we are here to help. We've been watching
you for generations, and we've never
harmed you. We've we've disarmed nukes.
These people are telling us that UFOs
disarmed nukes that even in the war with
Russia and Turkey u aliens came and
helped blast Russian tanks. So these
little seeds along the way are that
these beings are actually here to help
us. And once we start communicating with
them over
AI and start to trust them enough where
they say, "We want to come and we want
to help you, but you have to promise to
embrace us, to accept us, and to not
harm
us." What's that going to look like? I I
I've already talked to people on the
street. I've interviewed people on the
street and I said, "Do you believe in
aliens?" They said 99 said 99% said yes.
100% of the people that said yes said
when I said would you trust these beings
if they said they had the answers to
life and how to fix our world they said
yes 100% of them no one is even
questioning the intentions of these
beings and with all the propaganda out
there like oh ETs our friend to children
aliens are your friends so every
generation more and more believes in
aliens and believes that they're our
friend. Check this out, guys.
Okay, come and get me. You see that?
Aliens abduct me. A a
child. A little kid laying on the ground
saying, "Aliens abduct me." Now look,
look at his
shirt. His shirt literally has an alien
gray face. Like now it's not like, you
know, a pink tentacle monster. Some of
this more fictional type thing. They're
literally showing you the real alien,
the ones that people are seeing when
they quote unquote get
abducted literally laying on the ground
saying, "Abduct me." And then when the
spaceship comes, it literally looks like
the UFOs that people see. It's not like
uh Starship Enterprise or
some, you know, fantasy style thing.
It's really happening.
and he's excited that he got abducted in
the beam. The world is being groomed.
The world is being prepped. The
propaganda is out there. Kids are are
ready to embrace this thing. They love
the aliens. He becomes friends with this
alien and the alien protects him in many
different
situations. The stage is being set,
guys. Some of us have been seeing this
for a long time. God opened my eyes to
this deception in 2012 back when I was
totally hookline and sinker buying into
the ancient aliens concept. I mean I was
I had become a Christian. I was like
what do I do with this whole alien
thing? And ancient aliens came out and
said yeah Moses was led out of the
wilderness by a beam of light from a a
UFO. And I was like that makes sense.
Ezekiel saw a wheel within a wheel with
eyes all around it. They were just
describing a a UFO with lights around it
and they, you know, these archaic people
were trying to explain what they were
seeing and it made sense to me. That's
how deceptive the enemy is. He isn't
destroying the Bible. He can, but he can
twist it. He can say, "No, no, we
believe the Bible. We believe that Moses
was led out of the wilderness by a
supernatural thing. It was a UFO." This
is where we're at, guys. We show you
guys this stuff because we want to wake
up the sleeping giant. There are 10
sleeping virgins and five of them were
wise and woke up and the other
five were too late waking up and they
didn't make
it. So I want everyone to take your
relationship with Christ serious. Take
this journey that we are on. We were not
put here just to spend our time
meniously watching sitcoms, playing
hours of video
games. Like there's so much work for us
to do. And Satan has done a a miraculous
job of distracting all of us with
parties, drugs, music, movies, video
games, all these distractions to keep us
out of the word of God, to keep us out
of prayer, and to keep us from spreading
the truth that Jesus is coming soon. The
signs are all around us. It's
undeniable.
today. Choose ye this day whom you will
serve. Make today the day that you're
going to make changes in your life. And
you say, "I'm going to wake up every
morning and have devotion. I'm going to
pray for all those people that I know
are so blind and have no idea what's
coming." You might know. You might know
all the deceptions that are coming, but
think about the millions that have no
clue. How are you going to get this
message out? How are you going to share
this with them?
Please, if you were blessed by this
video, like it, share it with your
family and friends who have no idea
what's coming, and subscribe to this
channel if this is the first time you've
ever been here. We are keeping you up to
date on what's going on in the world,
where we're at in prophecy, and where
all this is going. It's all playing out.
We are living in Revelation right now.
If you guys want to support this
ministry, you can do so by going to
candidtruth.org. We got many different
ways to give on there. We actually have
a Patreon page now
and we have some cool t-shirts. If you
guys like t-shirts, go to
candidtruth.org and click on the
merchandise and we get about $5 a pop on
these shirts and it really helps to keep
this ministry alive. We can't do this
without you. We love you and we'll see
you next time on Candid Truth.